good day and welcome everyone i'm jack van
horn from the university of virginia please
allow me to welcome you to today's edition
of our 2020 2021 foundations of biomedical
data science seminar series this lecture series is
supported by uva's integrated translational health
institute of virginia the uva brain institute
the college of arts and sciences the school
of data science and through a grant from the
national institutes of general medical sciences
it is my honor and privilege today to welcome our
speaker dr shafali jeste associate professor of
residence in psychiatry neurology and pediatrics
at the university of california los angeles david
geffen school of medicine dr jeste is a behavioral
child neurologist specializing in autism
and related neurodevelopmental disorders when she
earned her bachelor's degree in philosophy from
yale university in 1997 and her md from harvard
medical school in 2002. dr jeste then completed
a residency in child neurology and a fellowship
in behavioral child neurology at the children's
hospital of boston she's conducted post-doctoral
training in developmental cognitive neuroscience
with the great charles nelson at harvard
medical school where she gained expertise
in the use of high density electroencephalography
to characterize functional brain development in
infancy and early childhood particularly as it
informs atypical development dr jeste's research
is focused on developing methods to improve
precision in the diagnosis and treatment of
developmental disorders from early infancy through
late childhood among her many accomplishments
she holds several national and international
leadership positions including the board of
directors of the american brain foundation the
board of directors of the national organization
for rare disorders the board of directors for
the international society for autism research
in 2019 she became the chair of the international
baby siblings research consortium and then also
in 2019 she was awarded the presidential early
career award for scientists and engineers for
her innovations in research in early predictors
and intervention for genetic neurodevelopmental
disorders today's presentation is entitled
clinical trial readiness for neurodevelopmental
disorders on the road to precision health as
always we are streaming this lecture live for
recording via youtube if you are watching on
youtube thank you so much for joining us today
also our specially selected 2020 2000 biomedical
data science innovation lab participants are
encouraged to submit any questions for dr jeste
via the chat feature of their zoom sessions
i'll synthesize all these questions and ask them
on your behalf during the last 10 minutes or so
of the lecture and with that welcome shafali
we are so excited to hear about your election
you're muted you would think after a year
of zoom i wouldn't do that so thank you um
jack and everyone for inviting me um and for all
those of you who are joining on a i was gonna say
friday morning but you're on the east coast
so a little later for you lunchtime break
um but yeah thanks so much for inviting
me and i'm really excited to speak with
you today um i love sharing our work with
folks with different backgrounds and i think
you as many of your data scientists are really
critical for the kind of work that we do
i'm going to keep this talk kind of high level and
really give you a big picture with regards to sort
of where we are in neurodevelopmental disabilities
and our efforts to really improve precision health
and clinical trial readiness but i hope that
as i do that um many of you who are really
you know again using your expertise to think about
how we creatively can use our big data systems
and our really complex data sets to help answer
some of the questions that we need answered
hopefully that'll help you know motivate you
inspire you to kind of get involved with this
field if you are not already and then i'm going
to make sure i keep some time for questions at the
end um because i'm not going into the weeds with
our methods especially with the eeg methods but
happy to answer questions about that at the end
um as we go so anyway thanks again for inviting me
and yeah so i'm a pediatric neurologist um these
are my disclosures none of which really have any
um bearing on what i'll talk about today um but
i'm a peds neurologist as jack said i trained
at boston children's hospital and spent some time
working with chuck nelson to really learn um about
you know what are the challenges and approaches
that we can take to understanding and studying
early brain development because we know
that brain development is what has gone
in some ways sort of a skew in neurodevelopmental
disabilities and so i learned some methods mostly
eeg and then moved to ucla in 2010 to be a part
of this large center that we call cart center for
autism research and treatment and what's pretty
cool about cart is that it's a very integrated
multi-disciplinary team where we have experts
not just in sort of research and early markers
and genetics and biomarkers but also experts in
clinical care and treatment and a lot of the work
that we do is to integrate those disciplines
to really ask these important questions about
how do we improve diagnosis and treatment for
neurodevelopmental disabilities um and you'll hear
a tiny bit about this clinic that i started that
is a multidisciplinary program called caring which
stands for care and research and neurogenetics
and it's a clinical platform where we evaluate
and then help to manage kids and adults who
have genetic causes for their neurodevelopmental
disability so what i'm going to do today is just
go through a few things so i'm going to start
by giving you this big overarching view on how we
think about precision health in neurodevelopmental
disorders it's a big buzzword in the field of
medicine right now across the board and it's
become a reality neurodevelopmental disabilities
which is super exciting i'm then going to sort of
shift a little bit and talk about you know sort of
a reality check on this excitement about precision
health and talk about you know what do we need to
do from the standpoint of clinical trial readiness
to make sure that when the therapeutics are
developed we're ready with the trials and that's
really the bulk of my research is in that space
and then finally just given the time that we are
in during covid i am going to talk a bit about
just quickly five minutes about considerations
that we need to be making both in clinical care
and research in neurodevelopmental disabilities
during this challenging time in kovid which seems
to never be ending especially in los angeles where
our rates keep rising um okay so just to get us
all on the same page since i know many of you are
not clinicians um what are neurodevelopmental
disorders so these are diagnoses importantly
that are based on behaviors so they're based on
a list of symptoms that are in the chapter of
neurodevelopmental disorders in our diagnostics
and statistics manual the newest version is dsm-5
what's important about these behaviors
is that they emerge early in development
and there's a lot of overlap in symptomatology so
the main diagnosis you'll hear about with ndds are
things like global developmental delay autism
spectrum disorder and intellectual disability
there's others like adhd and social communication
disorder but it's really global delay intellectual
disability and autism that you'll be
that you'll hear me talking about and
you'll hear me talking about work that's really
focused on autism but i just want to emphasize
that a lot of these developmental disabilities
overlap what's important to know though is that
there's a tremendous amount of heterogeneity
in these different diagnoses right so
you know you meet one there's a famous quote that
if you've met one child with autism you've met
one child with autism um but the reality is that
there is a lot of variability in how kids get to
these list of symptoms if you will um and part of
the reason for that heterogeneity is that there's
a lot of ideological heterogeneity now there's a
high genetic liability and we'll talk about that
but there's many different biological
and even environmental ways that one can
arrive at these developmental disabilities and so
that really is actually a challenge for us when
we're thinking about designing treatments or even
you know trying to identify clinical patterns that
we might want to target again with treatments or
with evaluations so despite all that heterogeneity
though our treatment model has really historically
been this so i see a kiddo in clinic say with an
autism diagnosis right so autism you have core
um symptoms or deficits and social behavior as
well as the presence of repetitive behaviors and
restricted interests or rbs so i diagnose a child
with autism and then i essentially recommend a
treatment and that treatment might be a behavioral
intervention or it might be a medication and then
basically what i'm looking for is whether those
basic core symptoms have changed so i'm measuring
quite crudely often that outcome which would
be again those core symptoms um and again the
treatment could be a medication or a behavioral
intervention but you know it feels crude and as a
clinician who's trying to be precise in diagnosis
it becomes a bit frustrating at times to then say
you know i've made this really precise diagnosis
and now i'm just going to have you go and you know
access whatever services your regional center or
your school system can provide you and we'll hope
that we see a change in your outcome we'd like
to move towards what we consider precision health
and i'm going to sort of operationalize precision
health in a few different ways for you guys but
you know the idea of precision health is that as
we start understanding causes a bit better and we
identify specific clinical symptoms that may be
more proximal to the cause we then can identify
treatments that actually might be targeting those
specific symptoms or even the cause and then our
outcomes that we're measuring might be a little
more specific again to that subgroup or to that
cause and ideally would be evidence-based so we
actually have data on what those outcomes might be
that might be measurable um so this is kind of the
basic rubric really simplistic of where we'd like
to move from the standpoint of more precision help
in neurodevelopmental disorders i love this
quote from um obama timely this week to sort
of quote him from his state of the union address
you know many years ago where he really put forth
a plan for a large federally funded initiative
towards precision health that was um largely
sponsored by nih where he defined precision
health as delivering the right treatment to
the right patient every time and i think that's
definitely a goal in our case as well i'll add a
few caveats so at this point the one caveat will
add to that in neurodevelopmental disabilities is
that we also want to make sure that we provide the
right treatment to the right kid at the right time
and timing is often we think key in these
developmental disabilities where we think
that changes are occurring even in utero right
so we'd like to try to target treatments as
early as possible which is challenging for
a variety of reasons as we'll talk about
so how do we even start thinking about precision
health and neurodevelopmental disorders like where
do we look given this big heterogeneous
behavioral set of conditions that we have
and this is where genetics has actually been
incredibly transformative and again i'm going to
summarize a bunch of stuff in sort of more simple
slides just to make the point but you know we've
had a lot of advances in how we examine clinically
examine you know genetic etiologies of disease and
and conditions um you know we just use the
basic karyotype to look at changes in the
number of chromosomes that's moved now to
using microarray technology to identify
duplications or deletions in the chromosomes that
are you know up to 50 or 100 kilobases in size and
then of course now even more clinically common is
is actually whole exome or whole genome sequencing
where we can identify changes at this at the level
of the single base pair which helps us to identify
single gene disorders um and with that technology
what's happened is that and this is just a rubric
is that we've actually identified um you know not
just these big single gene disorders like tuberous
sclerosis that we've known about for a long
time that cause neurodevelopmental disabilities
but also copy number variance syndromes
like 15q duplication syndrome that you'll
hear me talk about a bit later as well
as these very small single gene mutations
and now taken together you know
these don't account for all of autism
or all of neurodevelopmental disabilities
but the number is increasing in terms of
the number of um kids or even adults that we
identified that have these putative causes
and what's important actually and interesting now
is that with all that all the research done in
in sort of autism and neurodevelopmental genetics
it's now actually translated to clinical care and
now genetic testing is really the only routinely
recommended medical workup for an individual with
autism or you know intellectual disability um
and the clinical gold standard is that we do a
microarray and then some other testing based on
the sex of the child um whole exome sequencing
is often performed if the microarray is negative
because remember the microarray identifies copy
number variants it will miss single gene
um mutations and other kinds of very small
variants and so exome is performed there's been a
bunch of meta-analyses that i'm not going to show
here that have looked at the clinical utility of
whole exome sequencing and it's found in certain
cases where there's a high pretest probability
uh that the the um the yield can be as high as 50
so we're really moving into this place and the
next set of recommendations probably will include
whole exome sequencing so why is that important
well first of all we've identified now that about
25 of individuals with a neurodevelopmental
disability have an identified genetic cause
so we're starting to think about you know
can we learn something from these syndromic
neurodevelopmental disorders because we know cause
at this point right and then again if we think
about precision health we've opened a big door
um so before i sort of get into that um i want to
just make a couple of important clinical uh points
that i think are really relevant when we think
about these kids with identified genetic causes
so one is that clinically these kids do tend to
be more affected and i want to be really clear
about that sometimes you know people talk about
you know certain genetic conditions as
being models for autism or models for
neurodevelopmental disease and i always am very
clear to say like you know these kids with some of
these really large de novo mutations or variants
they're very clinically affected so they don't
represent the whole spectrum right they often
represent the end of the spectrum that are more
maybe clinically challenged in different ways
and what does that mean so these kids often
don't just have an autism diagnosis and i don't
mean to say just to belittle the importance of
that diagnosis rather that they don't they
don't simply have the social communication
challenges or repetitive behaviors they also
have global developmental delay especially
motor delays and hypotonia often have comorbid
intellectual disability and importantly often
have other comorbidities not just medical
ones but neurological ones like epilepsy
so in certain conditions we're seeing epilepsy in
up to 50 or 75 percent of children and epilepsy is
just having more than one um unexplained or un um
unprovoked seizure uh so you know these are kids
who are a little bit more medically and clinically
complex but you could argue these are also kids
where we're really desperate for treatments right
to really mitigate some of these issues that occur
over a lifetime the other really important point
though and again has been a really huge source of
advancement actually over the last many years
is that as these individual rare conditions
are identified right so again individually if you
noticed on the slide a couple of slides ago that
i showed you individually rare meaning each one
accounts for maybe at the most one percent of the
whole spectrum together again they they account
for about 25 but each of these rare conditions
what happens is with social media and all of these
other platforms these parents converge right they
communicate and they start talking about how
they can work together to really accelerate not
just a clinical understanding of these various
conditions but also really accelerate research
and so all these different parent groups
are called pads patient advocacy groups
and what they have done over the last i'd say
decade is really um improve our efforts in not
just supporting families and advocating but in
facilitating clinical care through developing
centers of excellence around the country for
specific conditions as well as facilitating
research and this is where again some of you's
data scientists might be interested but you know
one of the big challenges um for these families is
like how do we collect common data points across
all these different you know families that are
all over the world and how do we put them into
one registry it seems like a simple problem but i
cannot tell you how many groups struggle with this
and now there's efforts through this actually
group that you can see here agenda which is a
collaboration of all of these different pages
with which i'm involved and it's sponsored by
the autism science foundation the goal is to try
to have these packs talk to each other to try
to develop some common tools but they're really
working on developing registries developing bio
repositories and then ideally developing platforms
for trials and again i'm going to show you some
examples of that but these tags have been really
critical in moving this research forward but the
big data issue or not even big data just the data
harmonization issues one that they're all still
often struggling with okay so back to the
precision health right so what can we do
in neurodevelopmental disabilities when we think
about these genetic conditions well we can start
thinking about syndrome-specific treatments so as
opposed to a standard approach where you take the
whole sample of neurodevelopmental disorders you
choose a you know a random cohort and you identify
you know a drug that might be effective instead
we take a tailored approach and we identify these
subgroups that are again genetically identified
at this point and then think about treatments that
would be effective based on the understanding of
the mechanism of action of the uh of the genetic
change and that's exactly what's happened in our
field and again in the interest of time i'm not
going to go through the different methods i'm
happy to answer questions but you know there's
medications that are more targeted to certain
pathways there's gene editing methodologies like
crispr cas9 that's been very exciting and then
most you know most relevant right now are actually
these antisense oligonucleotides and so what is
an aso it's basically just a small sequence right
of rna that can bind to the transcribed rna and
change basically protein translation and so that
that technology has really been leveraged in the
last few years to be able to affect the downstream
effects of some of these genetic variants and i'll
give you one example which is not even really a
neurodevelopmental disorder but it completely blew
the doors open in child neurology i'll say which
is um the aso therapy for spinal muscular atrophy
so this is a devastating condition that affects um
you know the most if the most severe kind affects
kids in early infancy um where they don't have
production of a really important um protein
called smn and that protein is very important for
just the functioning of our motor neurons and so
when children have sma they don't have basically
strength they don't have any motor function and
so you can imagine that affects their respirations
as well as their movements and many of these
children actually die in the first year of life
and so an aso therapy was developed to be able
to essentially unsilence the silenced smn protein
that is again typically silenced in our bodies
because again they have a deletion of one of the
smn protein um genes and with that aso um this
this trial that was started again many years
ago halfway through the trial they found that it
was so effective that they stopped the trial and
made this an fda approved drug called spin raza
and now we've infants who are receiving this drug
who are living a full life i mean completely
curative right so it just shows that these
conditions that we thought were never going to be
able to be treated are now able to be treated and
i want to be clear i'm not trying to compare a
neurodevelopmental disability to spinal muscular
atrophy i'm just giving the point that you know
with an understanding of underlying mechanisms we
can actually develop treatments that could
be deemed as transformative or if you want
to use the word curative in this case i think
we would use that for sma and what's happened
now in the neurodevelopmental disability space
is that these aso and drug trials have been now
launched in various conditions and i'll just
point out a couple so tangelo is a rose trial
and it's an aso for angelman syndrome i won't
get into all the details but angelman is caused
by a deletion of ub3a which is a gene that's
maternally imprinted so in our in our healthy
brains we have a paternal ub3 that's silenced and
a maternal ub3 that's active and an angelman the
maternal ub theory a is deleted so what this
aso does is it unsilences the paternal uv-3a
um and we actually just had our first ucla tengelo
patient get dosed this week so incredibly exciting
again the data are obviously not out yet but the
goal is that we can at least slow down progression
or or even possibly reverse some of the
neurodevelopmental manifestations of these
genetic conditions so this is the era we're in
right now you know super exciting and i really
am careful as a clinician not to oversell these
opportunities because we don't know yet right but
if you think about where we've come from where
we were 10 years ago when we were making genetic
diagnoses that sometimes felt academic right they
let us they helped us inform parents about why
their child might have developmental delay or
not have language or have epilepsy or have autism
now we're at a point where we can say hey based
on a cause and based on our understanding with
pre-clinical models and everything else
the underlying sort of downstream effects
of that genetic variant or change based on
that we actually might have a therapeutic
that could really fundamentally
change the way the brain our brain
developmental trajectories are going to progress
and that's a very different conversation that i
have with parents now in some cases right than
i did many years ago and so it's really exciting
so as i get you all excited i also have to then
also be you know the tale of caution which is
that as these therapies are created we have to be
ready and what does that mean we have to be able
to have the data necessary to develop and design
and implement clinical trials that will truly
tell us if the drug works and unfortunately in
neurodevelopmental disabilities we've been stymied
by clinical trials being deemed as failures you
know and there's a lot of reasons for that and
we'll talk about it but you know we've had trials
where people have been excited about you know
drugs maybe more char you know for the broader
autism spectrum rather than for specific genetic
etiologies but a lot of excitement around trials
that then in the end you know the drug doesn't
seem to be more effective than a comparison group
and then it's you know never approved for use
and that really leads to some discouragement but
i would argue that it's probably not always the
case that it's because the drug doesn't work it
might also be because we don't have the right
trial design so let's talk about that for a minute
right so just again this is really basic 101 and
many of you probably already know this but it
helps when we think about again how we can um
you know improve clinical trial readiness
which is again going to be the bulk of the
rest of this talk so when we how do our trials
design so typically in a trial you know you
take your initial population of interest
and again there can be quite a bit of um
stratification that's done up front but you take
your population of interest and randomly split
them into two groups right and then one group
receives an intervention and the other groups
receive receives a placebo and i won't get into it
there's lots of different trial designs that um uh
allow for us not to have to do a pure placebo like
you know sugar pill or whatever so that people do
always have a chance to get treatment they're
staggered weightless designs and things like that
but fundamentally the idea with the trial is that
you're asking whether the intervention group uh
has made gains in whatever your outcome measures
of interest are have they made gains above and
beyond what we would see in patients who did not
receive the treatment that's the bottom line so
why are we challenged in um in neurodevelopmental
disability clinical trials especially in these
syndromes so what the first is that we don't
have great measures of drug target engagement
meaning we don't know if the drug actually hit
the target before we decide to then launch into
a one-year trial to follow outcome right so it'd
be really helpful to have some measures of that
the second and this is a big one is that our
standardized clinical measures that we use
to assess development cognition social skills
they often don't adequately capture function or
even change especially in these populations that
are more severely affected and i'll show you an
example of that and then lastly as you can imagine
i mean these syndromes are rare individually right
these kids are all over the country in the world
so how do we actually get a sample size big enough
right to be able to answer the questions that we
need to answer when you can't just recruit locally
right these kids are everywhere so those are i
would say the three really big areas of challenge
and so we in our group have actually been doing
research to try to address all of these areas and
what i'm going to do in the next like you know
uh like 15 minutes or so is kind of show you
examples of what we've done in these three areas
and again each of them could be their own talk
in the interest of time and also just to give
you kind of a high level view i'm just going
to show you examples but happy to answer more
questions about them and a lot of the stuff is
published or recently published as well so um
okay so the first is this issue of drug target
engagement right how do we address that and so the
way that we've sort of tackled this and again this
is not just my group this is the groups around the
country and world is that we can start thinking
about how do we identify mechanistic biomarkers
right that really inform drug target engagement
so biomarkers that we think reflect the putative
target of the drug and that we also think reflect
maybe some of the mechanism underlying disease
or disability in these in these um patients
um with regards to this issue around this the
challenge around standardized clinical measures
um we've been doing quite a bit of work thinking
about and developing through big cohort studies um
you know through an evidence-based approach what
are the most meaningful and measurable clinical
endpoints so we need to test those clinical
measures in these populations directly to then
be able to answer the question about test retest
reliability or stratification and those sorts of
things and then lastly from the standpoint of the
challenge around the rarity of these conditions
you know we've been working to design protocols
and develop methods that really maximize access
and scalability and this has become amplified
during covid because forget about whether someone
has a rare condition or not these approaches that
we take to figure out improved access are going to
be relevant across the board because right now
families can't travel even if they are local
because of restrictions and so we've had to be
really creative with that and i'll show you a
bit about that at the end okay so let's start with
this issue about biomarkers so what is a biomarker
right so biomarker is just any characteristic
that's objectively measured and evaluated that
indicates either a normal biological process a
pathogenic process or a response to treatment
there's a lot of interest and excitement about
biomarkers and autism right now and i'll just
mention that there's a large nih-funded autism
biomarkers consortium for clinical trials of
which we are a part jamie mcpartland at yale is
the pi and our goal is to use methods like eeg
and eye tracking to quantify some biomarkers that
will help us stratify kids with autism and might
be sensitive to change over time so this this
consortium study is not a trial itself it's really
a big data gathering initiative and some of those
papers have are getting published right now from
our first wave we just got refunded to start again
this summer um but you know you might ask well
what kind of methods and what kind of biomarkers
do we use for a neurodevelopmental disorder well
um this is again where genetics can help us think
about it and this is kind of a busy figure so if
you have a small screen you might not see it well
this is a great review by luis de la torre from
nature medicine a few years ago where he basically
looked at kind of what were the what are the
convergent mechanisms and pathways that
underlie these like hundreds of putative
genes that cause autism and neurodevelopmental
disabilities and it turns out not surprisingly
that the many many genes that are affected um
and that are causative really do impact these
basic neurodevelopmental processes like protein
translation and synaptic signaling and that these
effects and the initial effects of these genetic
changes occur before birth so this circle is
you know is um birth right so these are coming
online in in uto in utero fetal brain development
um and fundamentally again as i mentioned
they're affecting things like synaptic signaling
gliogenesis migration differentiation and when
you look even sort of at a slightly sort of
macro scale as to what these different pathways um
actually do affect at the level of brain function
they fundamentally affect brain circuit
function right so they're affecting the way
as i like to think about it the way the
brain is wired right so it's not that these
um that were we're seeing a break or a um you
know or a you know uh yeah a break in healthy
connections that have already been formed it's
that these sort of network level um you know
changes that are supposed to occur and typical
development are just not forming in the same way
and that actually led to this coining of the term
by dan geshwind and pat levitt many years ago that
autism and neurodevelopmental disorders were
developmental disconnections so again it's
these these connections are just not forming in
the way they might form in typical development
so how do we test that right and so again
a bit of an oversimplified slide and if
any of your electrophysiologists you might
appreciate this but you know we've been using eeg
as a really beautiful temporally sensitive tool to
really assay neural circuit function in real time
right so we can really probe that circuit with
scalp level um detection again this is a picture
of the kind of nets that we use but there's lots
of different ways that we can collect these data
and you know fundamentally what is eeg it's really
measuring at the scalp the synchronous firing of
neurons in real time right so it's a it's a fairly
nice you know somewhat indirect although i would
argue not so indirect measure of healthy circuit
function and development and there's so much that
we can do with the signal and i we my lab has
published a lot of eg papers i'm not going to
go into all the methods but just to say that that
kind of crude signal we get at the scalp we can
break down into component parts and calculate you
know the oscillatory power in different frequency
bands we can look at peak frequency and we've done
a lot of work looking at peak alpha frequency in
particular as a very sensitive measure of really
healthy brain development and we also can infer
connectivity so unlike with imaging where we can
really look nicely at structural connectivity with
eg we cannot do that but we can do is using tools
like um and signal processing methodologies like
coherence we can ask how in sync is the signal
in different parts of the brain and by doing
so we can infer how connected different um parts
of brain regions are okay so that and we we have
focused quite a bit on um alpha phase coherence
in our lab and so using eeg as a method um we
can really start to ask these questions about
you know are there robust biomarkers in these
neurodevelopmental disorders and i'll give you um
one example of the infancy work again and this is
again a talk unto itself i didn't want to focus
on that today because i'm trying to tell the story
around clinical trials but we've actually for a
long time been studying infants who are considered
at higher likelihood or higher risk for having
a neurodevelopmental disability either because
they have a genetic syndrome or because they have
an older sibling with autism um you know the baby
siblings group is one that's been studied for a
decade and jack mentioned at the beginning that we
have a large international consortium actually of
researchers who have been studying baby siblings
um and i've been sharing that consortium just
for the last year but um you know there's
been quite a bit of work in that consortium using
methods like eeg to study early brain development
and so this was a study that just got published
and abby dickinson who's a really phenomenal
research scientist in the lab worked with actually
a bunch of data scientists on this and took kind
of a um uh i'd like to think of it as like a
clear box machine learning approach where they
basically asked you know which networks which
set of networks which we called features um and
the networks were defined again by phase coherence
between two electrodes essentially which networks
most robustly um relate to and predict later [
__ ] scores and [ __ ] is a clinical measure of
autism but the nice thing about the way that they
did this algorithm is they were able to then go
back and look to see what the networks were so
they could be interpreted and what we basically
found was this pattern of hypoconnectivity or
reduced face coherence in frontal cortical regions
and a pattern of increased connectivity increased
base coherence in temporal parietal regions which
is interesting because those are networks that
have been for a long time in the imaging work
been implicated in autism right frontal cortical
regions being really critical for attentional
networks especially social attention whereas
these temporal parietal networks have been more
clearly linked to really social cognition
and social motivation so um again really
interesting work just got published and i'm
happy to share that paper with you guys but
our next step is really to replicate this right
in a larger sample but this shows that and sorry i
didn't mention this is in three month olds so you
know this shows that we can use eg to kind of map
these changes very early in development how robust
they are how predictive they are definitely still
needs work so i don't oversell the finding but i
just want to show that we can use eg in these ways
okay so back to sort of thinking about these
syndromes and how eeg might be a useful biomarker
we've been studying a bunch of these
different really highly penetrant you know
for neurodevelopmental disabilities genetic
syndromes and one in particular we've been
really interested in and i think it just is a good
example of the kinds of ways we can use biomarkers
to study these conditions is do 15 q syndrome so
do 15 q is a syndrome caused by a duplication on
chromosome 15 q um you can see here the um the
the region that's duplicated and there's a bunch
of really important genes for brain development
in this region including the maternally imprinted
ub3a which i mentioned earlier that's deleted in
angelman syndrome in do 15q it's overexpressed
and there's also a cluster of gaba receptor
genes and that's important because we do really
believe that gaba neurotransmission is profoundly
altered in these in these individuals and what we
know about do 15 q syndrome is that it's highly
penetrant for neurodevelopmental disabilities so
these kids have hypotonia global delay autism
as well as epilepsy what got us actually quite
interested in this condition is that there was
a case series that was published many years ago
where they were describing the clinical eegs
of these children and you know these kids get
clinical eg's undergo clinical eegs because
they have epilepsy so they need to get eegs
from monitoring and what was found was that these
kids had this sort of high frequency oscillations
on their clinical eg now as a neurologist when i
see this eeg pattern it makes me think about um
it makes me think the child's taking a gaba
positive allosteric modulator like ativan
or valium um so when you actually caught you know
increase gaba signaling in with pharmacologically
you actually get these high frequency beta
oscillations these kids are not taking these
medications so when we saw this we thought oh my
goodness this might be a biomarker of underlying
of that gaba those gaba genes being over expressed
in ultra gaba neurotransmission so let's try to
really quantify and study this biomarker and
that's just what we did and again this has
been published over the last few years this is
great work done by a couple of amazing graduate
students and a statistician named domina center
um but what we found using our signal processing
methods is that um in do 15q this is just sort
of like a heat map a topo plot just in the beta
band range which is like 15 to 30 hertz we see
much higher beta activity in duke 15q compared
to iq matched kids with non-syndromic autism and
typically developing kids this is a power spectral
density plot also just showing this big gaba peak
and this is was huge the effect size is almost
two here scatter plot showing the same thing
with the high beta and the kids would do 15 q
since then we've done quite a bit of work that
was recently published asking about whether it's
stable over time that biomarker the answer is
yes whether it's scalable can we measure and
quantify this not just in our research eg but also
in our clinical eeg answer is yes um and it's also
led to this very interesting path that i'm not
going to get into today but if you're interested
once it's published i'll send you the paper
we just submitted it where we started looking
at um eeg and sleep because i was wondering if
sleep physiology was altered given that we see
these high beta oscillations in the awake stage
and i thought if sleep physiology is altered
that might have a profound implication on
cognitive development and so we went down
this pathway um and found actually that there is
profoundly altered sleep physiology in these kids
not just in the fact that they beta at night but
in their slow wave oscillations and their spindles
and we think that's going to be a really
important actually target for therapeutics
so that's an example of a really nice biomarker
right and so taking it back to this rubric
of precision health let's just sort of
operationalize this before we talk about the
clinical endpoints which is kind of the next area
um which is you know imagine that we see a child
with dupe 15 q syndrome right here or has symptoms
right global delay autism some seizures and we get
the molecular diagnosis of duke 15q well imagine
now that we actually conduct our eeg assessment we
find this beta biomarker uh and then we have
the opportunity and this is literally in the
works right now that there are drugs that are gaba
negative allosteric modulators that actually can
reduce that over the over expression and the
over the excessive gaba signaling well then that
those beta oscillations might be a really robust
marker of drug target engagement to know that that
gabaergic treatment if you will that modulator
did hit the target that's exactly the what we're
in the midst of designing right now with some
um with some trials so very exciting and it's
really accelerated again and changed the way we're
thinking about how these biomarkers can be used in
trials okay so the next part that you know i
mentioned was just that so now we have these
biomarkers now what about meaningful endpoints
how do we even think about that i'm not going to
spend a ton of time on this um especially
because i know a bunch of you aren't like
clinicians clinicians i won't go into the weeds
on this but i do want to show you this because i
do again think as data scientists this is relevant
because we really struggle with sample sizes and
thinking about how to harmonize data in these ways
so we um you know with the same syndrome do 15 q
syndrome you know we wanted to really understand
what is the clinical phenotype and how do
our measures of cognition motor skills
and adaptive skills how do they behave
in this population because we're getting ready to
design a trial we want to know what our endpoints
should be and so going back to the slide i just
showed you what we did was we didn't just collect
data at ucla we actually took our team on the road
and we went to multiple family meetings where we
could collect phenotyping data we actually did
eeg assessments there as well for some of the
papers that i mentioned earlier because it was the
most effective way to get access to these families
and they were very responsive to that so what
did we find okay so the one of the first things
we found when we actually did our battery of
assessments and we also compared these kids to
non-syndromic autism is we found that these kids
have really significant motor impairment compared
to non-syndromic autism this is on the vineland
and this is on the mullen if you're familiar with
those measures so this is a parent report this is
direct assessment so big picture significant motor
delays and motor impairments above and beyond what
we see in non-syndromic autism this actually is it
has been corroborated in large cohort studies
like in the simon simplex collection which some
of you might know about where um they also did
a study where they looked at various measures
in kids who had causative genetic syndromic
basically autism compared to non-syndromic
and the biggest differentiator was age of
walking so later age of walking and kids who had
causative genetic variants so we asked well you
know our motor measures are really crude can we
develop more quantitative ways to assess motor
skills and i don't take credit for this work
this is a fantastic junior faculty member in my
lab who was a postdoc with me and now she's a k
um 23 to really explore this she used gate mat
technology to better quantify deficits and gait
in kids would do 15q this is actually a kiddo
with duke15q at one of the family meetings they
took this huge gate mat and schlepped it to a
family meeting to collect data and you can see
that kids would do 15q have different gaits than
kids with non-syndromic autism and specifically
what what this dr wilson found was that these kids
have slower velocity of gait as well as um shorter
step lengths um and this is a nice measure right
this is something that's quantitative you could
argue it's almost more like a bio in the biomarker
category than clinical assessment but think that
this is something that we can use to measure if
we think that some of these drugs will actually
improve motor skills probably in a way a little
less crude than some of our standardized measures
we also though did and i won't spend a lot of time
on this we did collect again a lot of standardized
data and you'll see where the challenges are and
again for you guys as data scientists i want to
show you this so you can think about how do
you how do we think about solving some of
these problems so this is just um a cognitive
assessment called the mullen and we just did
age we call them ratio iqs so it's really the
age equivalence over the chronological age
and even using that kind of ratio iq score you can
see and again a hundred is considered quote normal
right look how low these kids are most of these
many of these kids are at the floor particularly
kids with seizures so kids with seizures are more
effective than kids without that's sort of a known
phenomenon in clinical medicine but you know we
have kids who are really falling on the floor so
how do we use those measures when we want to maybe
target cognition as an end point for a trial right
um interestingly though when we actually look at
other measures of functioning like the vineland
which is a parent report measure of adaptive
skills we see a bit better stratification and
kids aren't quite at the floor as much right now
that may be partly a bias of parent reporting or
it might be that that measure is actually just
collecting data that is a little more sensitive
to subtle abilities that these kids have but we
like these kinds of measures that have a histogram
like this versus one that has a big left shift but
we have to contend with this because these are the
measures that we have to work with right um and
so you know we based on that work and this paper
just got published actually you know we've been
really thinking about how can we be more flexible
and ident in studying and testing cognitive
abilities in these kids um you know there's other
questionnaires we can use to look at comorbidities
and social skills like the srs and the cbcl
and i'll tell you that we struggled with those
measures for these kids with more significant
disabilities because some of the questions that
are asked of parents are just not answerable
so for instance you know on the srs and it's a
great measure the srs has a lot of strengths and
value to to it but you know some of the questions
are things like you know your child's aware of
what others are thinking or gives unusual reasons
for doing things well if a child's nonverbal um
you know that's going to be a difficult question
for a parent to answer so then we get a lot of
missing data so we have questionnaires we're
missing a third of the answers because parents
don't know how to answer it how do we deal with
that how do we use that as a measure of outcome
right so those are sort of issues we're still
grappling with and ones that hopefully some of
you can help to address but taking us back to now
this rubric of precision health again you know
we talked about the biomarker in do 15q well now
based on some of the studies we've been doing with
our larger cohorts we can start being a little
bit more precise with thinking about outcome
so you might not use a ratio iq score or a full
iq we might use quantitative motor skills we're
definitely going to be excited about asking about
adaptive skills and maybe we'll use raw scores for
our developmental or cognitive assessments because
even one behavior or ability that's gained might
be meaningful right so but we're gonna really
change the way we're thinking about outcomes based
on the kind of data that we're collecting and
this work is ongoing and there's a lot of sites
around the country that are sort of collaborating
on thinking about these challenges okay good i'm
doing well with time so the last couple of pieces
i'm gonna try to be done in about seven or eight
minutes and then i'll have time for questions um
so lastly is this issue about that the fact that
these syndromes are rare i'm not going to spend a
lot of time on this one i just want to emphasize
that we are working hard as a field to develop
protocols that are more accessible and i'll give
you one example so this is we've been studying
another rare condition called tuberosclerosis
details don't matter actually for the purposes
of what i want to talk about what i will what i
will emphasize is that tsc is often diagnosed in
utero um these kids have these benign hamartomas
or tumors in the brain this is a fetal mri as well
as in the heart that's the fetal ultrasound that
are picked up early and and what we also know is
that more than half of these children end up being
diagnosed with autism so we've been over the last
10 years studying these infants prospectively from
early infancy to ask are there early predictors
that we can then target right can we start getting
these kids into early intervention early on
and what we found in all this work has been
published this is in the blue box we have found
that by 12 months of age we can identify pretty
robustly delays in non-verbal cognition social
communication skills and actually with eeg we've
identified biomarkers of atypical development
both in peak alpha and in phase coherence that
relate to later neurodevelopmental outcomes so we
have these robust measures right and so what's the
obvious next step well we need a treatment and so
we designed and were funded a couple of years ago
through nih to run the first randomized control
trial of behavioral intervention for infants with
tuberous sclerosis and this was a intervention
called jasper that was developed by connie castry
ucla it's a really beautiful intervention that
really targets some of the core symptoms that we
were identifying in tsc so it targets joint
attention and social communication skills
and so our question was basically do infants
who receive weekly jasper do they show better
neurodevelopmental outcomes than those that do
not and we have like a weightless control design
so everyone eventually gets jasper but some kids
have to wait three months because we felt like
ethically we wanted to make sure everyone had a
chance to get the treatment because they never had
access to this before and the way the study was
originally designed was that they were coming in
every week to either ucla or boston children's
hospital for the intervention there was a lot
of excitement around the study when it was when
it was launched and you know social media and
the press and the patient advocacy group everyone
was getting excited about this and in our first
year of funding this is an r01 so this is not
trivial amount of funding this was our enrollment
table so yellow were the number of families
enrolled so you can do the math and realize
that is not enough families our goal was 60. but
the purple dots were people who were interested
but didn't enroll so you can imagine why right
or maybe you can't but what what might be an
issue right look at that map right these kids
are all over the place and essentially parents
said we just can't do it it's not convenient
basically and one parent actually said if virtual
ever becomes an option we'd be interested so we
went back to the drawing board and we basically
converted the entire jasper study which is
called jets jasper early intervention for ts
to a remote delivery um parents still have to come
in once at baseline for the eeg and the assessment
but after that what we do is we give the parents
an ipad um and the they get trained once in person
this is just a picture in the interest of time
i won't show the videos but the um examiner base
or the interventionist teaches the parent in real
time um about the intervention and then the parent
goes home and practices and every week they upload
their video on their ipad to box it's very archaic
but it works the interventionist then downloads
it from box reviews it and then they do a zoom
call once a week and this was pre-coded that we
started this every week there's a new module the
parent gets trained again remotely they practice
same cycle uh and so the whole thing is parent
mediated done remotely so we made that change
and within six months this was our enrollment
map and we've continued to enroll we're not done
with the trial yet but it's been super exciting
and i think that that and we just published
actually that paper to describe the methods
and you know there's there's lots of studies now
this is an angel in natural history study that's
all remote right or mostly remote with in-home
assessments because we all recognize that it's
hard for families to come especially when they're
geographically dispersed and have kids with
complex medical issues so that's a great example
and we're doing a lot more work in that area now
okay so i'm gonna end with like two minutes
on this because i just think it's an important
thing for us to all sort of be on the same page
about which is how have we had to modify things
and how we had to think about these families in
the era of covid and i'll highlight a really nice
letter to the editor that john constantino wrote
with joe piven and some others recently about you
know just the impact of covet restrictions on
individuals with idds um and you know what they
said this quote i thought was really powerful and
i see it every day when i see patients in clinic
which is that among non-infected persons
in the u.s there's there's few more
adversely affected than individuals with idds and
why is that guys well you know these individuals
they rely on intensive services especially in home
services right that they're not able to get now
they need more close medical monitoring
which is also hard to implement remotely
they're also more overall vulnerable to the
impact of the educational mitigation efforts
right not being in school during the day zoom
is very hard for a child who has significant
intellectual disability or has autism or limited
attention um and so this is really important and
so we actually did a survey to really understand
the effects of covid on individuals with idds ndds
and the first survey was done in april and that
was already published and we're doing a second
wave actually now but just some highlights and
again that paper just came out so i can share it
with you or you can find it on pubmed but you
know important facts like more than half were
unable to see at least one health care provider
you know third three quarters lost access to at
least one educational services um and we had a
handful that thirty percent had lost access to
all their services um but you know interestingly
when we asked parents what would you like to see
you know preserved access to clinical trials is
one of their biggest priorities like they want
to still be in trials they want to still
be involved with research and so we have
to think about how to keep moving forward even
though we have these challenges and and these um
restrictions um and so we've made a big shift in
a lot of our research and clinical care a lot of
the stuff that i described that we're doing we're
you know the biomarkers work the clinical endpoint
work we're still doing it we're just having to
be more creative right so we're incorporating
telehealth quite a bit more we're working on
validating remote behavioral assessments and
this is a big consortium-wide effort with the
bsrc and some others we're figuring out ways
to collect biomarker data remotely through signal
processing of clinical eegs even portable systems
um and you know we're just thinking about
how do we do all this while preventing this
widening of disparities that that inherently occur
for parents who don't have access to technology
the same way that some of our moral resource
parents do um we have been bringing kids back to
the lab for eeg though and i'll show you some of
the things we've done we moved our entire control
system outside of into the hallway this is one
of this is my one the hallway of my lab all these
doors are eeg testing rooms actually this is
one of our rooms the parents on the inside with
the kid they become the behavioral assistant
so we have no one in the room with the child
so the parent does everything we coach them
ahead of time send them a video and all kinds of
documents to help them get ready to prevent their
child from pulling at the net and those sorts
of things um uh oops sorry i hope you can still
see my screen um but our control you know system
is outside we have a plexiglas wall here so if
there is an examiner on the side they're at least
separated a bit from the family because the kids
are not wearing masks usually just the parent is
but we're doing a lot of these different changes
and i can talk to you more about that um now that
i'm done so i'll just end with this right so we
talked about precision health right delivering
the right treatment to the right patient every
time at the right time and you know i just say
that right now in covid we also have to think
about how do we do all that safely and accessibly
and that's been sort of something we've
spent quite a bit of time contemplating and
you know persevering through over this last few
months um and with that i'll stop and just say
thank you um for listening we have a bunch of
funders that we appreciate greatly this is my
amazing lab um pre-covered um you know now we're
doing a lot of things on zoom this is actually a
group of students who are working with me this
summer and we had to coach and mentor students
completely remotely this year so that was
i'm sure you're going through the same thing
and it's definitely a learning curve so with
that i will stop and i'm happy to take questions
okay should i stop share are you guys
hi sorry about that i just needed to unmute myself
and couldn't find the button thank you so much for
this is a fantastic and wonderful talk this is
just uh very very well done it is a tour de force
amount of work and so congratulations to you and
your team for for all of it i want to start off by
asking you a quick question yeah which you kind of
covered you covered biomarkers and eeg and genetic
testing and cognitive assessments etc he talked
about some of the treatments that can can go on
um and and some of the effects of those
treatments and their their effects on
cognitive and motor results and then clinical
endpoints and hopefully cures for some of these
sort of disorders one of the questions i wanted to
start with is can you discuss some of the ethical
issues involved in the start points you
know we want to get to end points obviously
but where do you start and you kind of mentioned
children being genetically tested in utero um you
mentioned you know some other things about you
know when these things would start in childhood
to hopefully kind of head these things off the
past what are some of the ethical issues about
this that you've encountered and that you
know people discuss in the field that people
might be interested in knowing about great great
question jack and i think um there's actually a
few junior investigators in the bsrc mostly
working with ibis which i didn't mention
today but ibis is the infant brain imaging
study um which is the imaging consortium of
infant's infant siblings and i have a actually
an r01 that actually has added eeg to ibis and so
we're we work quite closely with them um there's
a whole subgroup that's been developed on this
question about the ethics of early screening and
detection and so there's a couple of things so
first if we if we think about just the early
screening detection forget the genetic testing
piece first it's just what are the ethics around
you know identifying early risk markers right and
when i say risk markers i mean and there's a lot
of controversy you've been using the word risk so
i'm using it as a clinician meaning i'm thinking
about you know identifying markers that herald
high likelihood of having a neurodevelopmental
disability later right which comes with you know
challenges and a lot of costs and other things for
parents and healthcare providers over the years
the question becomes if our predictors aren't 100
accurate right that's one and two if we do not
have actual treatments for all of these conditions
if you will especially if it's polygenic risk or
not a known genetic cause then what are the ethics
behind that right is it ethical to tell a parent
you know your child with a 50 chance of having
autism when there's nothing that we can actually
recommend um from a treatment standpoint to change
that trajectory um and the answer is we don't have
a great answer that there's a lot of dialogue
about this there's a lot being actually written
in the field about this um but you know there
are so the argument pro screening is that simply
by more closely monitoring and providing just the
basic behavioral interventions that are available
we do believe that we improve outcomes um
compared to what we would do if we never had
that early screening and surveillance going on
so those are the pros right the cons though are
that you know it's adding stress to families right
we're telling parents well there's a good chance
that you're gonna have more challenges but we
can't tell you for sure you know and we know that
parent stress family stress those also are not
always protective right of of healthy outcomes
so there are absolutely arguments prone against
and we get asked this question we write grants
in this area also like you know how do you
mitigate the stress that you're causing families
by you know you know with this kind of work where
you're just following and screening so closely so
it definitely is a challenge i would say that
you know then the added question around genetic
testing um you know now there's prenatal genetic
testing available you know through maternal
blood we can do it right and you
can do microarrays and other things
and we are not at a point where we have gene
therapies or therapies for all of these causes
nor do we know a hundred percent what the outcome
will be in some of these very rare variants
and so there's a lot of controversy over the
clinical value of performing this kind of
genetic testing very early so i think we're at the
epicenter of these of these um debates and i think
it's going to be a really interesting you know
next five years as we sort of really sort out how
we um how we handle that i think you're absolutely
right some of these questions are you know the
technologies are possible right it's those but
some of the ethical questions about when to apply
them at what point in development or you know
who knows if you wait you don't see something
in a child wait two weeks maybe it'll show up but
if you do something before that you could you know
actually cause more harm than good one thing
i wanted to uh ask you about from some of our
participants is do you think any of the
approaches might be effective perhaps as
protective treatments for neurodegenerative
disorders affecting older adults
great question and i think that the answer is yes
i think it is possible you know there's sort of
this again and my mentor chuck nelson has been
a part of these debates about you know are there
critical periods in development are there you know
they're just sensitive periods are there times
that you know is there a point in development
where it's too late right and i don't think any of
us believe that at all i think that thus far there
just have not been robust enough trials in adults
especially with some of these more what we would
call disease modifying therapies to know if we ca
if we would see a change or not so i think it's
worth exploring um i do think though like word of
caution is that you know kids are not just little
adults and so the kinds of measures we're using
the expectation of change you know even our
biomarkers need to be different in our in our
young populations compared to what we might expect
to see in adults um but but i think that the adult
spaces is and i have actually a junior the abby
dickinson who did that who wrote that paper that i
showed you on the um kind of machine learning with
eeg in our highest defense she's actually writing
a k right now to look at to look at sort of aging
in autism and to ask exactly this question so the
the measures that seem most sensitive to cognitive
development for instance in early infancy are
those also sensitive to aging processes might they
predict neurodegeneration or aging in autism so um
so that's an exciting year kathy lord's going
to be her primary mentor and they're working on
that right now so um some more to come there but
it's a good question that's really cool and well
another question is in us as people are looking
at these various biomarkers and looking at these
profiles across different disorders whether it's
autism or other you know developmental delays or
you know any other um sort of things are people
seeing some sort of commonalities across them
that would suggest that you know there's actually
fewer independent diagnoses than their you know we
might have uh uh carved the the population up into
does that make sense yes and actually i and i saw
that question in the chat and what i will say is
that and this is for all of you data scientists
i want a figure like this with eg so my point
i would love to see and it's not going to be
it's it's going to be complicated because eg
there's it's fraught with variability i'll just
say that right but you know we yes i think that
you've like you know convergence at the level of
genetics but there's going to be convergence at
the level of sort of macro level circuit function
um and yes i mean there may be other kids for
i mean the simple examples there may be other
kids who have high beta that might be um
amenable to similar treatments that might
be effective for do 15q for instance right but
we need the issue as again and i sound like i
actually didn't say it a lot in this talk i say
i say it all the time to my lab and to others is
we just need big data right like we can't
identify patterns and subgroups with sample
sizes of 50 kids with a range of like we need and
so you know i've been working one of my big goals
at the bsrc was to try to harmonize eeg data
across all of our sites that are collecting eeg
um and we haven't really gotten there yet and
there's just you know it's details us actually as
to why it hasn't happened um the ibis study that
i have that i didn't mention the ibis grant that
i have you know this is joe pippen study where
they're prospectively um imaging babies and it's
a it's a substantial sample size of 250 infants so
we got a grant to add eeg to that study so at the
end of the four-year ibis study we will have eeg
prospectively collected and imaging on 250 infants
so that will be i think that'll give us
some nice um that'll hopefully get us in
the right direction here but really we would
ideally want sample sizes that are even larger
you know to really ask like are there eeg
patterns that help us select kids for trials
well with that uh shafali thank you so much
for sharing the work of your laboratory your
your thoughts and vision for what you
would like to see in this space and i
completely agree um large-scale data across
multiple biomarkers across multiple uh
constituents of our population are really going
to help get some insights into some of these
developmental disorders as you described so thank
you so much i appreciate it um everyone thank
you enjoy your weekend and we'll see you again
next week thank you so much awesome take care